so how would you choose a topic for your
project this is going to start with
those of you
that are just planning to right you are
just thinking about
developing a project idea and maybe
you're thinking
how do i do something like a publication
that i
read or maybe you're thinking how do i
do something in
an area where i'm naturally interested
in but i really don't have the data
to start doing that kind of an
experiment
so that's the first point that i think
we should start
from is the topic that you already know
and care about so if you're currently
doing
uh your phd you've selected a topic
you're maybe thinking of a particular
experiment
and you want to understand how to make
it more impactful how does omics data
factor into this if you're already
conducting experiments and you've
collected data
you might be thinking how do i find
additional data
that i don't have the capability to
generate myself
but i really want to use it to make my
project more impactful
or i want to develop a new hypothesis
but i don't have the means to generate
the data
so that would be the first step is
really having
a topic that you know or you care about
and to ask yourself is that a topic that
i know and care about
is can you prepare a few slides to
explain
the topic background and can you see
yourself spending a few months
researching the topic so really for
those of you that are planning some kind
of bioinformatics analysis
even though it's just data analysis it
still takes time
so you have to be prepared to dedicate
at least several months
just to the analysis the second part
is what will be interesting to your
audience so i'm assuming that the
majority of you here
are already in some kind of research and
so if you think about
your audience what is that audience that
audience could be
your peers your mentors other faculty
they could be the broader research
community and
this is not a trivial question for any
of those audiences
within a niche there's already a niche
within
every domain there are specific topics
that are more
interesting they're more on top of
everybody's mind
and so that's the second component here
the third component is that you have to
have the data
and you have to have um some kind of
a body of research
that is available about that topic right
so if you are planning to conduct this
research
and there's no data you're back at the
same place right so it's got to be
something
that comes from availability of data
now in between at the intersection of
these three
is the project that you want to focus on
and i want to talk about this a little
bit more
in detail because that's where typically
most of the participants that we have in
our programs
fail they fail to quickly identify
a relevant topic that is interesting to
a broad community
and find data that can help them
make some kind of an interesting project
out of that question
so i think that defining that question
making it specific
and making it um actually possible to
execute
is a big challenge that needs to be
overcome
now when people publish they typically
publish from primary data that they have
collected
and that is the raw data the first
hand observation that they have
themselves collected
in many cases you are not going to be
the person that generates that primary
data because
so much data is already available but
that doesn't mean
that you cannot start your project from
there
and so what we will do in the context of
the first part of our program
is we're going to kind of explore all of
these
sources of data to generate a hypothesis
or develop a problem or a question
and then find the solution or the answer
and i think that that has to do
with an overview of literature but also
the available data sets
and it has to do with a good founding a
good
established understanding of methodology
how
have others extracted insights from data
sets that they described
and so the typical process that we
recommend
is to start from where you are and try
to
define what is the specific
data set what is the problem statement
that you have
and then trying to work through on how
to make that
into a much more specific question
because that really
can help you then narrow down the number
of options that you have to do
your analysis and it will
streamline or simplify the
interpretation at the end
and so the first part is to review
available sources
and to categorize them by some kind of
type for example you can think of
different types of research articles
that present the current topics or that
focus on one specific thing
you can focus on a number of different
categories but you have to build out
that overview or that kind of a
landscape
of where you are compared to what's
already out there
and then it will be more clear where are
the specific
gaps unanswered questions
maybe controversy right so some people
don't agree with each other
and maybe a debate and those are
typically
the most interesting things to address
so that
gap those unanswered questions and those
debates around
different topics is the place to focus
to define your question or hypothesis so
here what we want to do is we want to
kind of review what's out there make it
more specific
where do we want to focus and that
typically
will be in the place of gaps and
unanswered questions
now a good place to start is from
existing projects right so a part of
review
and by the way this doesn't have to be
just in your domain
is to see how have other people
try to answer questions with data
and so what we've done is over the past
several years we've gone through
publications that focus on specific
types of
problems and specific types of data and
have extracted
insights from that data by processing
exploring and analyzing those data sets
so we've collected
a number of projects that you can
start with as a springboard into the
process
because they clearly take out the
methods
break down those methods into tutorials
that you can follow
explain the data set and how the data
set was collected
and why that data set is an impactful
way to study that particular topic
and once you've gone through a few
examples it becomes
almost easy for you to start thinking
about the data
in terms of a hypothesis that
could be answered with a given set of
tools
and so when it comes to your project
you are really going to be able to take
those examples
and leverage the same types of methods
to apply to a data set of your own
so this is how the program that we
envision
is going to work we're going to first
follow through
and learn about some of the basic data
types and how they are processed and
analyzed
then we will introduce case studies and
those case studies will provide you with
a good overview of the topics
where the data came from how it was
analyzed
and what are the results at the end
you should develop a framework of how to
apply
such thinking to any new data set or a
problem
that you identify and so then we will go
to focus on your independent project
where you will frame the problem and
framing the problem means
writing out the specific question and
how you plan to address it
then we'll go through finding the data
sets and that data
will be of different types and different
formats that we will review
process the data for analysis with the
right tools and today i'll show you a
few examples
perform in-depth analysis trying to
develop a statistical model that can
either prove or disprove your hypothesis
and then we'll also work with you on
communicating the results of the
analysis which is a very fulfilling
process
because it helps you get feedback early
on
from a community of like-minded people
that will point out
all of the details that you need to
address
for your final project so let's take an
example
and think about how to frame the problem
what does that actually mean so there
are several types of problems out there
for example you can take a clinical
problem
right so we all live in the era of
personalized medicine
and we can think of clinical challenges
in the context
of personalized medicine for example
patient stratification
how do different patients respond to
different pathogens
how do different patients respond to
different treatments
are there specific groups of patients
that we should be aware of
disease classification and diagnostics
how can we differentiate
one disease from another maybe one
disease staged from another disease
stage
maybe it is the predictive component how
can we identify
potential responders to therapies that
will respond
better to a therapy based on our mix
data for example
and also we can look at mechanism of
disease and disease progression
and that is more of a research question
and nevertheless
it plays a major role in how all of
these other questions could be addressed
another category of problems are related
to intervention
and so for the pharmaceutical and the
biotechnology companies what is
important for them
is to know biomarkers how can we
understand
specifically what is the molecular
process
that can help guide our decision making
that can help define
a diagnostic test we can think of
detection of toxicity right when there
are interventions
how do we know that those interventions
can have side effects and those side
effects
could mean toxicity at the maybe in
vitro stage
as well as an analysis of molecular
mechanisms of a drug action or target
discovery right so how can we use the
information that we have
about a particular interaction between
an intervention and the host
at the molecular level and understand
what are the targets
that we can focus on and how to
eliminate the targets that are
potentially
unreachable or unrealistic and also a
big domain
in everywhere in including infectious
diseases and non-infectious diseases
is drug repurposing and repositioning
right so how can we take
existing compounds and apply them to a
different type
of a challenge or how can we take
the same drug and combine it with
another one
or maybe modify its mode of use so that
it is positioned
in a different way so after we framed
the problem we need to find the data so
let's take a look
at a few data sources where you can
potentially identify
a data set for your research okay
so i'm going to go here to ncbi
and please follow with me to ncbi
this is the link
and please let me know once you've
reached ncbi
by putting yes into the chat box
and as we're doing that i want to say
that
the majority of the people that have
answered the first
question said number one so they're
already working
on a data of their own they've collected
their data they're
doing some analysis themselves and nine
people
said two so nine people said that
they're still
planning or thinking about a project
okay so please let me know once you've
reached ncbi by putting yes
in the chat box thank you encourage
all right thank you okay it looks like a
lot of you
have okay so
another question for those of you that
already reached ncbi
on a scale from one to five one being
no experience and five being expert
how many of you have experience or what
is your level of experience working with
ncbi so one to five five
you're an expert one you don't really
know
this is new to you
all right so i see that hosea
wrote number five so i'm going to pass
on the microphone to jose he's going to
guide us
on a brief explanation of how to use
ncbi
that that's a joke so for those of you
that are
very familiar with ncbi
that is a great thing what i think we
want to do today
is just look through some examples of
data sets that we can quickly find and
i'll show you how you can use them
even if they're very large even if
they're something that you
probably don't want to download to your
computer and
load up your laptop with this data set
so
here we have a search box on top
that searches for all databases okay so
think of any concept that you're
interested
in or any topic that you're interested
in and let's just see
what's out there so i'm going to take
the first five
examples that you post in the chat so
put down something
more or less specific okay so not just
the name of the organism
or a disease propose something a little
bit more
detailed a little bit more specific so
what type
of a data set what type of a problem
statement what type of a question do you
have
that we can try to find data for
okay i'll take the first five
suggestions from the chat box
okay any suggestion does anyone have any
project in mind that they
don't mind sharing with the rest of the
group
okay so whole genome sequence again
whole genome sequence
is going to be a little bit difficult to
define because
that could mean anything right whole
genome sequence of what
what pathogen what okay great
so ahmad you can try again um
let's go to the next one gulshan tairoba
nyc tuberculosis
um so i don't know if that's referring
to new york city
or uh did you want to say mycobacterium
tuberculosis but again that's broad
right that's very broad that's just a
pathogen okay
let's go to the next one almataio is
saying drug target for parkinson's
disease
okay let's try that okay so drug
target parkinson disease
that would be number one okay
a bukari is saying microsatellite
sequencing data
again something i think a little bit
broad let's be more specific
applied to what what kind of a disease
or or something like that
okay a beer is saying
rna microarray data for the lnk
gene okay so
i have a little bit of a problem with
that because if you're using
microarray you probably don't want to
just choose one gene
right instead choose a pathology or
choose
a specific situation where this type of
data will be interested
let's go on hosea is saying comparative
genomics of
covet 19 strings okay perfect so
covet 19 strings we don't even have to
search anywhere we can
look over here source code 2 data so
we'll take a look at that example and
see what kind of data is out there
human microbiome and soil transmitted
hellmann's okay joelna aquari is
asking a very interesting question so
that's gonna be number three
let's see what we can find for for that
and this is personally i do not know
anything about this topic and that's
what's exciting about my job i did to
learn about all of these interesting
things
uh from you okay uh james
so we have one two three four so this is
the fourth okay so we have here
alka tenuria disease
james i would recommend being also a
little bit more specific
just the disease itself is probably too
broad so think of a more specific
question let's go to the next one
muhammad sagir shahu is saying
single nucleotide polymorphisms of ace2
i think it's interesting so let's take a
look but
i would mention that it's probably also
very broad right so let me first of all
fix this h2 okay so the last one let's
see
who's going to be the lucky person
plasmodium falciparum that data okay so
that's interesting but let's
again be more specific let's go to the
next one
mance mansonella species in africa
okay let's let's try
[Music]
okay so let's go to the first one
so the first project that you proposed
was
drug target in parkinson's disease
and so let's take a look briefly at what
types of data
are available and how much so there's a
lot of books and publications
and different kinds of references in
literature which
obviously we would expect but here we
have some information about
genes now who knows what does geo
stand for does anyone know what geo
stands for
gene expression omnibus okay thank you a
beer
that's in fact correct so we have here a
number of gene
expression data so we don't have a lot
but we have
a few data sets now let's think whether
gene expression is a good way to study
drug targets for parkinson's disease
i think it is a good uh data type
because
when we look at how a drug
affects a particular tissue or a cell
line or a whole
whole organism what we really want to
know is whether
there is a protein a receptor on the
surface cell or some kind of a surface
protein that could be accessible for a
drug
is playing a major role in this disease
and therefore if we interact with it we
can potentially make a difference we can
change something
so i think that's a perfect example so
let's take a look at what kind of data
do we have here
as a drug target for parkinson's disease
so here we have
gene expression of a53t and corrected
ipsc driven
to d8 neurons and exposed to paraquat
and menin okay so a lot of gibberish
that i personally don't understand so i
would love to learn more
and i can click here for more and read
about the organism experiment type
summary
the overall design and potentially even
a publication that i could read
but let's go and see what do we actually
have what type of data do we have here
so
here it says we have 12 samples
and the important part to think right is
how can this data
inform me about making a
reasonable question that i could be
answering with such data
so what i see here is that we have four
different groups
in each group we'll have three replicas
and those replicates
are corresponding with some condition so
if i was to start looking through the
data sets
i would need to structure the data in
such a way that i can
ask questions by for example making a
contrast
between one group and another group
or maybe through classification where i
can identify
different features that are specific
that are unique
to a particular condition so it looks
like
if i'm interested in finding a data set
to start
asking questions about some particular
drug or a pathway for a new drug target
this would be a good data set to start
okay so
for the first one we found data in about
a couple of minutes
let's go to the second one so here
it's obvious that we're going to find a
lot of data every lab in the world that
was shut down for any other purpose
found a way to repurpose their research
to study source code two and so much
data has been generated
just in the context of this pandemic
that it surpassed
every other pandemic before this
including ebola virus cells one
zika etc in fact we saw a four-fold
increase in the number of genomes
generated every month
for sars cove two compared to all of the
other
types of uh previous outbreaks combined
so i think there's a huge number of data
sets you can see that there are over
185 000 sra runs
so who knows what sra stands for
i'm assuming uh some of you that put
number five for the previous question
are very familiar with these
abbreviations
so please let us know what does sra
stand for
[Music]
all right excellent thank you a beer
sequence read archive exactly so
here we will find compressed fastq files
that contain
sequencing read data and from those
sequencing reads
we can study gene expression genome
variation
we can identify groups of different
viruses
inside patients etc etc so over 185
000 of these 53 000 nucleotide records
so
genomes or genes or proteins clinical
trial data
publications and references so really a
whole
collection that you can scroll through
so i'm not going to go in detail
anything you want to ask about
coronavirus most likely somebody
generated some data that you can find
and study that let's take a look at this
one very specific problem here
human microbiome and soil transmitted
helmets
so if we look here we're struggling to
find
any raw data we have some publications
we have some books but we don't have any
data set so let's try
to find nevertheless what is going on
with these soil transmitted helmets so
the first thing that
i already know that there's a lot of
data on the human microbiome
so i can pause with that real quick and
look for soil transmitted helmets and
see if i can find
anything for that and it looks like i
can
now because i'm interested in the
microbiome
i know it's not going to be in the gene
expression omnibus data because that's
going to be gene expression
and i'm looking for microbiome a
different type of data
so probably i want to go into the bio
project
and see what can i find here
and here i do have one bioproject that
deals with the metagenome
okay so what do we have here the impact
of endometric treatment on human gut
microbiota in western kenya
cross-sectional and pre-post deworming
comparisons
i think this is exactly the type of data
that you're looking for right i forgot
who asked this question
but do you think this is a data set that
could help you study this topic
okay whoever okay great so there's your
project
so here you have 211 samples
already for you right you don't have to
generate a single sample
because first of all you probably want
to understand
whether this data set contains some
interesting insights
into what you are trying to identify so
there we go
a complicated challenging research
question and we found data for it in
just a few minutes
all right so another question was single
nucleotide polymorphisms of ace ii so
whoever asked that please add a little
bit more detail in the chat box so we
can kind of take this further
but it's an interesting question we all
have heard
that h2 is the primary target for the
coven 19 source code two virus
we know that h2 is expressed in the
lungs and other tissues
and maybe the question is whether there
is a genetic component
to people that have acute reaction to
source growth ii or a milder reaction to
source of 2
maybe some other types of information
like ethnic background
or other important information could be
a factor here right
so obviously we're going to find a lot
of data here
but i think we need to structure the
question better to find
good responses so ace2
how do we find single nucleotide
polymorphisms
single nucleotide polymorphisms are
found in
genome sequencing data and so instead of
looking for
single nucleotide polymorphisms in h2
i would just probably want to find some
data set
that i could query or i could search
through
to find polymorphisms typically found
in maybe a healthy population or maybe
between different tissues
or potentially between different species
as i can see here
right so if i focus on the homo sapiens
h2 let's search for that
okay here i have
again bio projects
so let's take a look at bio project
okay here we can clear all because we're
in the filter for metagenome
and because this is going to be genomic
data
unfortunately i don't see genomic data i
see epigenomics
other which i don't know what that would
be transcriptome so
it looks like maybe we need to
search through um so so
whoever proposed this do you have a more
specific question here
okay i'll wait for you to come back
because i think that here
in the context of ace 2 it would be
interesting to
see what the specific question would be
that does it have polymorphisms probably
yes
do you want to just compare different
people or do you want to find a
particular
position or how do you want to use that
information right
that's i think where you need to think a
little bit more and propose
how to make it more specific okay so now
let's look
we have manzanella species in africa
so again unfortunately this is kind of
broad
right so i think if we just look for
manzanella
and then we see what kind of information
do we have about
manzanella it looks like we have some
geo data some gene expression data
some bio project so let's take a look if
any of these
are in africa
okay let's see where was this collected
if we can find out
looks like a very recent data set
a genomics okay
do we know where it came from
let's see
[Music]
um
okay unfortunately it does not tell us
where was collected from and it's a very
recent sample but i can imagine that you
would be able to
find data depending on
what is your research question what are
you trying to find right
so the point of this is that i think for
the majority of the projects that you
proposed so three out of five
we found data very quickly for the other
ones
it took us a little bit of time
primarily because
you need to be very specific when you're
asking the question
just like those three good ones asked
right it's the microbiome
for this particular pathogen and we
found that data right
once you can define your question with
the type of data
the type of a organism the type of a
specific
question that you have that helps you
very quickly
answer the question about whether that
data exists
and remember let's go back really
quickly to that slide
when you choose your problem you need to
care about it right so
some of you have proposed your questions
presumably you care about them
number two it has to be interesting to
your audience so that's up to you to
decide
but three that's an important component
you have to have
a data set to start working with to be
able to work on that project
so that's an important component here
that we always go through
so we've thought about how to frame the
problem
again several examples of how to frame
the problem
and how to explore whether that problem
could be answered with data
now let's talk about processing the data
so
many of the data sets that we have
looked at will
require processing of raw data for
example when we looked at the sequence
read archive
those contain individual read reads
from sequencers those need to be
pre-processed
then they have to be mapped they
potentially if it's gene expression you
have to go to
quantification maybe differential gene
expression
or you are free to start asking the
question
what is the signal to noise ratio what
kind of signal am i looking for
that can help answer my question so in
the context of this program
we'll take a look at several types of
data sets
including viral sequencing or
metagenomic sequencing we'll take a look
at
genomic data how whole genome sequencing
whole
exome sequencing or genomic genome
assembly
for pathogens works and we'll also look
at transcriptomic data
so we'll learn how to process that data
to go from
individual reads to a table of
expression
a big step that many people overlook
is the exploratory data analysis step
so as we saw we found
a number of data sets and those data
sets
have been prepared by different labs
different
hands did the sequencing they did it in
different conditions
we need to know that the data is solid
that we can use it that it doesn't have
any artifacts that are going to lead us
astray
so let's see whether we can find some
data set
and quickly explore it okay
so here we have expression profiling by
array i'm just going to use this example
to show you
what kind of data exploration could be
meaningful
in this case here we have
six or sorry three replicates per
condition
so let's take a look how can we explore
this data
so here we have the table so let's
download this table really quickly
it's going to be a big table but we'll
take a look at what's inside
okay so i'm going to take this table and
let me
unzip it
okay i'm just going to open it up
in excel and let me read here a little
bit more
what does this data describe so
parkinson's disease pd is characterized
by extensive loss of
a9 dopam dopamine
dopaminergic da neurons in the
substantia and negra pars compacta
snpc okay
okay a strong association has been
reported between
pd and exposure to mitochondrial toxins
such as the environmental pesticides
fairquatman eve and retinol
here using a robust patient-derived stem
cell model of pd that allows comparison
of cyanuclean
mutant cells and isogenic mutation
corrective controls we identify
mitochondrial toxin-induced
perturbations
specific to a53t syn mutant
a9da neurons we report a novel molecular
pathway whereby
basal as well as toxin-induced oxidative
and nitrosate of stress inhibits the
mef2cpg transcription network in a53t
hns compared to corrective controls
contributing
to mitochondrial dysfunction and
apoptotic
cell death our data provide mechanistic
insight into gene environmental
interactions in the pathogenesis of pd
furthermore
using small molecule high throughput
screening we identify the mef2cpgc1
pathway
as a new drug target for therapeutic
benefit in pd
so here we know that this is a mutant
right this is a53t mutants so
a53t this is the mutant
uh and here's another a53t
a53t right so what is pq
and so i think that these were
um paraquat maybe
mb paraquat and moneb and rotnum so
maybe these are the pesticides
so maybe this is the mutant with
pesticides this is the control with
pesticides
this the mutant without pesticides this
is
the control without the pesticides so my
question would be
as i want to explore this data could i
use
would i be able to see clearly
differences between
the control group and the treated group
or between the mutant and the control
so let's try and figure that out
so here's my data i'm going to just
change this to id
and actually i'm going to use
uh i'm going to use this because right
now i'm not interested
in specific genes here
i have the names
of probes it looks like
so what i okay okay so this
is not useful okay unfortunately with
this data set
it is designed around probes and so i
cannot just take
the data set as a table of expression
what i probably will be able to do is
get the raw data
and find that data inside okay but
theoretically
what i would want to do is i would want
to explore this data using something
like principal component analysis
to see whether the groups separate and
the important next step here
is to be able to structure this
analysis in depth right so here
we have an example of what i wanted to
show you unfortunately the data wasn't
ready for it which is actually
80 of the case that's what you're going
to find but once i structure the data
and i find the right table
i could perform something like principal
component analysis
that would help me design the specific
contrasts
that i could turn into biologically
interpretable
analysis okay so i'm going to pause here
and ask you if you have any questions
about what we did
and how you are thinking about
your own project so help does this
ability to find reference data sets on
ncbi
and public domain repositories does it
help
your project do you see yourself being
able to leverage these resources
to be able to ask such questions
okay so the other example that i briefly
wanted to show you
is this one okay so the second
problem that we will take a look at
today
is working with large numbers of data
sets so again
you can see here is there 211
samples okay so to process these samples
you actually don't have to download the
data to your computer so in the context
of our program we're going to provide
you with
access to our server platform
that is a big data platform so please go
with me to server.tnashbio.info
and we'll take a look at the second
dataset
okay so here what's important is
to understand how was this data prepared
okay deep so maybe you could share the
demo account details
okay so what's important here is to
understand
how this data was prepared and you can
see here
that this is amplicon data
using aluminum my seek and it is
metagenomic
it's pcr and it's paired and
because it is metagenomic using my seek
i probably think that this is going to
be amplicon data
so what it's going to simplify for us
is that it's only going to provide us
with sequencing of the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and that will allow
us to study
data about microbiome composition
and species richness so if i want to
analyze all of these datasets again one
of my options is to download all of them
to my computer
and start running a pipeline on my
computer but
i can see how this can quickly get out
of control because there's just so many
samples
and each one of them is fairly large
so instead of doing that what i will do
is i will send the results to run
selector
or over here go to
file and download the run
info table and what this will
do
okay what this will do is it will create
a table
from which the server will itself pull
the data from ncbi
and i will be able to run this analysis
without requiring any kind of
computational
power from my own computer so let me
show you how to do that
okay here we have the runs 211 runs
and here there's a download link which
typically i could use
using sra tools to download to my
computer but i'm going to skip that
okay so here we also have
the description okay they were taken
from different
dates it looks like
and
all of them okay so this table
let's go to the server could be analyzed
with either the data 2 pipeline
right here or kind 2.
so let's use this amplicon 16s
example to see what we can learn
from this data set so here we have a
demo
of what this pipeline would look like
and so i'll just briefly explain
once the data is loaded you go through
the data data2
workflow which clears up the sequencing
reads
and prepares a table of operational
taxonomic units
that is then cleaned up and
prepared for analysis using phyloseek
that will show us how the distribution
of species in different samples varies
based on in this case i think infection
so as a result you will get a number of
outputs that include visual outputs
and table outputs that could be further
used to study these
in detail how do we actually upload the
data
instead of the demo now with the
credentials that beeps have provided you
cannot do this but
once you join the program you'll get
your own personal account
here i have the ability to
select silva as my reference database
i will add the file that i just
downloaded
as an ncbi run table so i'll do add file
and here
i'll take this table that i uploaded
and here i actually don't have
a supplementary text file
but i'll just upload something else and
now i can
start this pipeline so without
downloading
any of the files just providing the
reference
links to ncbi and defining what groups
those samples would fall in
i can start this pipeline and create for
myself
a full metagenomic analysis
understanding species composition and
richness
between those different samples in the
microbiome
okay so briefly i think what we went
through today
is how to find data
which could include looking on ncbi like
we did today
it can include raw data on different
repositories like
sra bio projects and geo
and other dedicated databases
for example somebody mentioned
plasmodium falciparum
so there is a full database of data
specifically on plasmodium falciparum
plasmodb then
we talked about how to do exploratory
data analysis
and that can include running something
like principal component analysis or
looking at
summary statistics for my data
understanding whether
i can use that data and make reliable
inference from my analysis
then we talked about doing meaningful
analysis
translating my question into a model
into a test in a particular analysis
that i will want to run and finally
you will get to your result so
what is the result what should be
included
in the result of my analysis
so as we said in the beginning you start
with the project name
and selection of your topic you then
perform
specific tasks you downloaded the files
from somewhere
you analyze them in some way all of
those steps need to be recorded
so what's going to be important in the
context of this three-month program
is the ability to keep a journal where
you record
all of this information that later on
will be included in your poster in your
report or in your publication
so there you will describe who generated
the data
and how what are the sample names and
how do you find those samples
if somebody else wants to reproduce your
analysis what are the specific
analyses that you've run how did you
transform the data or manipulate it
before you ran an analysis
and so all of those tie in into your
results and discussion how does your
result
compare to what other people did
especially if you took some
other people's data and what
does your analysis contribute what
new information does your analysis
contribute to what is already known
about this topic